[Music]
what's up guys today
is gonna be a an interesting day because
i am getting a i have a hair appointment
and i'm not getting a haircut today oh
my hair is pretty nice right now got a
haircut last week today i'm gonna get my
hair
permed i know you're thinking what
casey's gonna get his hair permed
unexpected i guess so because uh i've
never really been one to like
get stuff done to myself or whatever but
getting my hair permed has been one of
those things i've always toying around
with in my head because uh
you know ever since i was a little kid i
hated my super super straight hair and
if you're
an asian person uh most asian people
have very very straight hair
and it's just like a it's just like a
one look kind of thing
like there's not a whole lot you can do
but you have to go out of your way to
get
texture in it create volume in it
otherwise it's like a
straw kind of thing it just kind of
sticks up
if you don't really tend to it and then
when you comb it it's super super
straight
living with this kind of hair for 30
years of my life it's kind of boring so
maybe the k-pop scene has uh influenced
me to
try getting a perm i'm not necessarily
looking for a k-pop
look when you think of an asian guy with
a perm though the first thing that comes
to mind
is the k-pop look i'm not too sure what
i'm gonna look like with the perm
i'm really really nervous actually i'm
here at my hair place eddie's
edition we're gonna find out how i look
with the perm
[Music]
all right so i'm here with eddie eddie's
my hair guy and uh
i've been actually very very interested
in getting my hair texture to look like
his
eddie you've got like a wavy
naturally wavy hair so hopefully my perm
is going to look like that today hi
you're going to do my perm today cool
are you ready
yeah i'm nervous are you nervous
i hope you're not nervous
[Music]
transformation convincing
i get a cool hat too yes
the the heat hat thing is really warm
it's not
cold all right so 10 minutes has passed
and now we are looking
i like that too i'm getting a perm
before starting i thought for some
reason the chemical would burn my head
but
i don't feel anything yeah
[Music]
all right so i just texted tiff a
picture of this
she said i look it looks like i'm in
russia and i'm wearing like one of those
big
like russian hats or something like that
but she says i'm a rich russian
guy it looks like i'm wearing some
burberry stuff right now
she's actually not worried about how it
will look because i'm actually more
anxious about this doing this than she
is she's just like well if you don't
like it you can always cut it off or you
could
put a hat on so i'm like that's a good
point so she's really called me
calmed me down and allowed me to go
forward with this because i feel like my
anxiety about doing anything crazy
and this is not even that crazy i feel
like but you know doing anything out of
the norm
my anxiety would stop me from doing that
so thank you tiff for helping me calm me
down
[Music]
cool this is really fasting it's like
wait ten minutes
then five minutes and now eight minutes
uh yes oh cool and you know i blocked
out my my day to be here for like three
hours
[Music]
i'm washing my hair out it's already
curly
[Applause]
[Music]
cool hey it feels different running my
hands through my hair feels really
really interesting
now cool
[Music]
i got my perm what do you guys think
i like it actually i am a fan i was so
worried that it was going to be too
curly or like too intense
um but this is kind of like this the
size i was hoping for
and then uh so obviously i can't style
it for the next couple of days and i
can't
put any shampoo in it so i just have to
like wash it like just kind of rinse it
with water or whatever conditioner is
okay they said
and get to explore this hair
get to explore um styling it explore
just kind of playing with it and see
what it can do and cannot do so
super excited now i'm heading home to
see what tiff
and isaac think about my new hairdo what
do you think of my hair
oh it looks the same
it looks the same and once it happens
once it dried it kind of straightened
that a lot huh only going away this is
kind of cool though
yeah i like this yeah it's out of my
face yeah it's like always poking my
face oh but this thing still goes bad i
know this is the part where i'm like oh
i was hoping like all this would just
kind of go to one side
play around with it though next couple
of days we'll see what happens
oh i like this color just did that that
was nice
yeah and it's like way softer it's like
yeah it like changed the texture of my
hair which is great
it feels like way lighter like when i
when the wind was blowing and like it
was just like all over the place i was
like
oh this is what it feels like to have
different texture yeah because usually
it's like really thick and heavy
yeah this time it's like it feels like
this is what isaac feels like
when his hair blows i'm like oh this is
great
because otherwise my asian hair is like
so heavy and like so it's like straw
and it's like pokes like it pokes me in
the face and it hurts
what do you think like your perm yeah
yes
kind of looks like your hair i'm trying
i'm trying to reach that level
yeah i like it sweet thank you very much
i brought i brought fluff for you
i didn't tell him because i wanted it oh
nice did you just eat i smell bacon in
the air
oh yeah i made i made a not just it was
a couple hours ago oh okay gotcha
no i made an omelette nice some ham
salt and pepper and oregano oregano and
omelette
he made fancy first one for himself and
it came out a little bit too salty but
then
i asked him i requested one and then he
made me one and it was like
perfect nice i thought i needed more
salt
yeah i tasted the edge though chef isaac
isaac's taking a liking to
uh kitchen and hell hell kel's kitchen
[Music]
gordon ramsay's show where uh you like
watching him yell at people are you are
you learning about like the culinary
world though
in some ways you're picking up on like
how chefs operate and
conduct themselves and the importance of
food and recipes
pretty much yeah that's cool i like that
more about a feast on this yes so i
brought home some fur
not not the cat the cat i did not bring
home to eat that's that's just isaac
being weird
i brought back some pho for isaac and
then uh me and tiff
we're gonna go in on some sushi
so ever since ann taught me how to make
sushi at home i've been i haven't had i
haven't had a chance to
test out my skills by myself so today's
the day i'm going to make some sushi
rice
and i'm going to cut this fish oh my
mouth is uh
salivating already all right so now that
i've had this hair for a couple of hours
i safe to say that i think i could have
gone more i think i was expecting a
little bit more i think it was a nice
entry-level attempt but i guess the
worst thing that could have happened is
if i went like hardcore hardcore i'm
like i want curls and stuff and then
end up being something like a little too
intense for my taste i think this is
like i can live with this but then the
next time though i'm definitely going to
try and do even more curls
and see what happens after all right so
yesterday tip and i
spent the whole day no one looks like a
bowl cut
i really like a k-pop star donut
yesterday tiff and i
uh spent the day fixing up this room
this extra room that we've had it's
always been kind of like our postedly
office room slash baby room storage room
it's been the storage room for a long
time and now we've finally transformed
it into its
first step towards being functional
other than being a storage room which is
an office room now
and bam
you look comfy in that chair futon
yes it's a futon so i am loving
the process so far so this doubles as
a guest room and an office and
on this side like where casey is sitting
right now
this space right here we're gonna get
rid of that white chair that's gonna get
put away and then right there it's going
to be
the office desk that i had at at the
other
jk office the white desk all right yeah
and everything else here is actually
you know remember from that day where we
moved all the stuff from the jk office
well here it is
yeah so then that white desk i'm gonna
paint it and i was thinking about
painting it
like a pink like a little blush pink
blush very very faint
pink yes yeah putting it in that corner
and that would be like my vanity slash
desk area because right now i'm using
this true
the workspace true you look comfy though
it looks like a really like
you're just missing like a little coffee
or something and
a little nice little workout spot i mean
a workout spot or your office spot
working spot yeah we're gonna paint
these walls we're gonna do some sort of
design or a stencil
i'm not sure and then put up some
artwork that that will be the office
until we can make it a nursery
oh yeah and you were also saying like
how you're actually feeling a lot more
active and like positive feeling because
honestly our house does not get any
sunlight except for the back
two rooms which is this room and isaac's
room
and the garage yeah because the sun just
happens to only hit from this side of
the house
the back of the house and so our master
bedroom doesn't really it's really
gloomy
and so is our just like the living room
every area
so just compare this room right yeah we
don't get we i'm not able to do shadow
dogs ever in any other room except for
this room
yeah and then look look at how gloomy
and sad
it is just like right here yeah it's
just so
gloomy and gloomy and then like the
windows are open
we don't just we just don't have them
like all the way open but yeah and the
sun just doesn't hit
a different like time of year here
there's like winter time or there's
summer time
winter here summertime yeah we also did
this too so we moved the shelf
from the office and then we moved it
here and i'm probably gonna
get other things to spruce it up some
more but in the meantime
this is here we still have to put this
rock under the bed
and it's literally been like forever i
don't know it's been like five months i
feel like i don't know i'm exaggerating
but it's been a long time
we'll get to it it's been here oh my
gosh i love this room
i know it's like raiding radiating with
energy over there yes this is so
pretty so nice and then once i get my
desk here it won't be so echoey true
you can like hang things but this is
cool
i like it but yeah so this is the first
time making sushi without
supervision let me know what you think
oh nice
yup i had a hard time figuring out where
to start on the piece of fish
and also i expanded on the on the menu
i bought tuna and i also bought um
yellowtail
i like you in your computer glasses oh
yeah the blue like cute
it looks so cute oh yeah then look too
we put this cushion
from the office i put it here and then i
asked michael if he got rid of the other
one he said no so he's
he's saving it for us and i'm gonna get
it cleaned and then we're gonna put on
that side
oh nice finally my booty's to be all
nice and
passionate cushioned yeah i was like
wait what is it i also made the sushi
rice by myself there was no exact
measurement that uh ant gave me to work
with it was just kind of like it's a lot
like you have to feel it through so i
was like all right hopefully i added
enough
vinegar rice vinegar into the rice
hopefully i cut the
fish relatively okay for consumption and
um
for you oh i don't want wasabi it's okay
wasabi makes my eczema go crazy
zoe is interested in the sushi
crazy i know sushi things smell nuts
when it's just by itself like the rice
burger smells crazy
the fish smells crazy wasabi smells
crazy i don't know we didn't use wasabi
but when you put it all together though
it somehow
ends up being magical so what happened
there
magical dude looks so funny
he smells the fish
[Music]
i know that was not very yellow for
yellowtail is it
halibut no it's yellowtail oh wait i put
ponzu with salmon
is that a thing sure oh yeah that's what
we had last time yeah
good yes yes
oh yeah it was a good bite not bad i
need to do some control on the sizing of
the rice though i got
i got huge clumps of rice without
realizing how much rice there was
you know how you do one and then you do
another one and you do another one and
eventually it just starts getting bigger
and bigger bigger
i started doing that but hey you got an
in-house sushi chef now
don't insult sushi chefs i'm just
kidding
i love you love you too
[Music]